senator feinstein introduces bill to
require proof of vaccine negative test
or documentation of recovery for
domestic flights
the u.s air travel public safety act
would order the department of health and
human services and the federal aviation
administration to develop national
vaccination verification standards and
procedures the text of the act says that
it is necessary to reduce passenger crew
member and airport personnel risk of
exposure to covet 19. decrease the risk
of transmission of covet 19 on board
aircraft in the united states uh and to
united states destination communities
through air travel
and protect children and other
vulnerable individuals by preventing
further spread of kova 19 in the us
under the bill a passenger would have to
provide the air carrier with
documentation demonstrating they are
fully vaccinated provide proof of
negative pre-departure or alternatively
written or electronic documentation of
recovery from covid19 after previous
infection all right well that last part
at least i can give some respect to but
across the board i just don't have much
respect for this at all i think it
doesn't go far enough let's put it let's
put a scale like there when you check in
let's just check people's bmi if it's
too high you can't get on the plane i
mean it's about saving lives yeah
actually you're right that's a great
point so there's actually an issue with
overweight people on airplanes because
when an individual comes on a plane they
actually there's a there's a load
manifest i used to i used to work with
these and you write down average weight
of cargo
depending on how many people are in the
plane and how much cargo how much
luggage in the plane the pilot has to
behave differently and move people
sometimes there were issues where there
was like very little uh luggage and
they're like okay that's gonna displace
the weight and put all the weight in the
front so they'd actually ask people to
move to even out that weight things like
that so yes people would complain
because they'd be like sir you're
overweight you have to occupy two seats
because we can't have the displacement
on the plane this way people didn't like
it
so what are they allowed to like if
someone has the flu can they not fly you
can fly sick you always have to be able
to it's kind of a dick move but i guess
some people you know are in a bind and
they can kick you off the plane for any
reason they're playing
private company well they're not i mean
that's what we're seeing is they're not
right i mean if there's if they you know
there's an example of companies that
aren't really private companies it's
airlines right they're not the fact that
the government can do this is is an
example of how they're not remotely
private companies if we had private
flight think about how awesome it would
be there'd be it'd be like not that
megabus is like the most awesome
experience
they'd be way closer to megabus there'd
be you know tens of thousands of
airports you'd fly out you'd drive out
to the middle of nowhere you'd get on
the plane 20 minutes after you got there
you wouldn't have to show id to anyone
there'd be all kinds of flights it would
be way more decentralized some random
pilot can you know rent a a plane and
fly you places that's what a free market
in air flight would look like we don't
have anything that remotely looks like a
free market you'd also be standing up
so they've actually experimented with
this yeah they're seats where you're
slightly sitting down they're like
straight up and they have a little like
hump on it where you can lean against
but you stand the whole time and they're
like we can get way more people on the
planes if we do this well i mean give
you know what like that can feel awkward
and understand but just give people
choices that's the point like if people
want to fly on a flight where everyone
is vaccinated let the market provide
that service if people don't give a [ __ ]
let the market provide that service when
the government is stepping in and saying
this is the way that planes have to run
that's not a choice that's the
government coming in the gun in the room
and saying you have to operate your
airlines you could do a roller coaster
flight as long as it's safe where every
so often the plane just drops a little
bit and then keeps going and drops as
long as it's safe and then you get the
roller coaster feel on your flight you
know perfect that'd be fun yeah if
people
why don't they do vacs and novak's
flights sure but it's but it's public
health this is the thing we don't want
to spread travel is not should not be a
privatized in my opinion the roads the
railroads the planes should not be
privatized because someone can be like
no you can't travel because i don't like
you i don't like what your dad said to
me 20 years ago you're never allowed and
then he's like all his friends that own
all the other companies like yeah okay
him and his family forever that's a
problem of monopolization yeah which is
maybe an argument for rhodes but i don't
think it's an argument against planes
because planes it's so easy there's so
much space we're not running out of
space there's no monopoly on it there
can be there's no reason there shouldn't
be a hundred thousand
possible ways that you could fly you
know like think about how many people
are uber drive like flying would look
like uber much closer to uber not
necessarily where you're getting on your
plane in 10 minutes but it would look
much closer to that when you have this
vast variety of providers it's heavily
centralized in a small number of
companies because the federal government
made it work that way well they actually
are doing like uber for planes there's
companies where it's a private plane and
then you can you you basically say
here's where i'm going to this place the
faa shut some of these down by the way
oh wow yeah it's a it's a story to check
out there were some successful companies
doing this cfa faa came in and said
that's illegal wow yeah sounds right
well that's the government i guess i
guess they think of planes as weapons
because they they're so big and move so
fast they can cause destruction if they
ram into stuff so they're treating them
kind of like dangerous weapons you're
gonna
what this basically means what they're
doing is all putting pressure on anyone
who opposes their agenda because you
know for the most part
a lot of most people are like oh the
vaccine's fine i guess but it's really a
decision between you and your doctor
that's what they're eliminating they're
taking your private choice out of the
equation and they're doing it in a way
that most like most people are probably
fine with and what i mean by that is
most people are like i get it vaccines
are fine
they see the data they say the news
there's an argument some people don't
like it but for the most part they're
like well you know it's
i get it right there's there's a
pandemic there's a crisis you want to
get a vaccine fine
the problem is they always use issues
like this to erode your rights they're
never going to come out and and demand
you do something ridiculous like you can
no longer have shoes and people would be
like what you can't do that no they do
something where they're like in this one
instance where it seems reasonable
you'll agree with us and then once you
give us the ability we'll do it for
everything so this this is going to turn
into a negative test but that's going to
turn into a negative test for everything
then it's going to be like you can't
travel if you're sick in any way
that's insane 15 days to slow the spread
just because we don't want to overload
the hospitals but we know it's going to
be here 15 days is all we need they want
to stop people from flying it's gone so
haywire look look aoc said they wanted
to stop people from flying that was part
of the green new deal yeah and there and
it seems like i'll tell you this they're
exploiting a crisis in every way
possible
to stop people from using look the
market's collapsing right we've got
economic crisis money being printed like
crazy people are fleeing cities shipping
containers all jammed up in in
california unable to come in they don't
want you buying stuff they don't want
you making stuff they don't want you
burning fuels they don't want you flying
on planes they don't want you driving
and so you got all these people in the
cities locked in a little cubicle
cubicle apartments losing their minds
well i think i think one aspect of this
is like politics is about tribal
dominance and the best way to dominate
someone else is when you can say this is
actually for the good of everyone and
that's why this situation has reached
this kind of front democrats want to
dominate republicans republicans want to
dominate democrats and this gives the
democrats a chance to dominate the
others in this way that is ostensibly
pro-social but it's really about
punishing people that they don't like
and i will i'll say this is also why the
free state movement is so important is
because libertarians need their own try
and it's not working nationally
libertarians need their own tribe as
well but right now a lot of this is it's
about tribal dominance and the fact that
it's about public health i think that's
pretend
well it's the the problem with
libertarianism is that people are
individualist
collectivists naturally have people who
will get behind them and say just tell
me what to do and i'm down whereas
libertarians are mostly like don't you
tell me what to do so have you found
like decentralized methods to unify
individuals
well the free state movement is pretty
decentralized so i'll i i'll give a like
a little bit of legalese here the free
state project which is the organization
that i'm representing all we are is the
marketing department we don't engage
politically all we do is try to talk
about how awesome new hampshire is for
libertarians the free state project is 1
100th of what the free state movement
represents so i'm like blm inc and then
you've got the free state movement right
like if when someone puts that blm sign
and decides to hold a rally they didn't
consort with blm inc they just did it on
their own and so most of what happens in
new hampshire is bottom up it's
decentralized is there fighting between
some of the libertarians of course there
is you can't get three libertarians in a
room without them you know fighting each
other um but i think it's by far the
most successful libertarian movement out
there and the nature of it is it selects
for people that want to win it doesn't
select for people who want to be you
know popular online or or want to go
into their you know dc crowd and and be
friendly with people that are their
enemies or that want to dominate them
it's a it selects for people who want to
actually achieve who actually want to
win and i don't think you're going to
find a movement that's much more
effective have you experimented with
like decentralized voting um for
localized voting like on apps and things
like that and finance with tokens and
things like that yeah i mean i love that
stuff of course to actually you would
have to actually change new hampshire
laws to get that uh one thing that does
exist in new hampshire because there's
like seriously like 100 different
organizations that play these kinds of
bottom-up roles and i'll give you an
example one that's related to that
there's a group called liberty ballot
and for people like i hate i hate voting
i think voting stuff i don't want to
vote honestly like i would i like the
idea my ideal society is uh is that of
restaurants uh you know i have no uh say
on what's on the menu but i have the
choice of where i want to eat uh
competitive dictatorship
but i want to support free status so i
vote when i'm in new hampshire i don't
pay attention to politicians i go on to
a website called liberty ballot it's run
by free staters free staters take the do
the job of parsing all the candidates
and saying these are the liberty ones
and i go in and i just check the box for
who they tell me to vote for and so
there's like
so many institutions and organizations
like this that are filling all these
roles that make the movement successful
that sounds crazy to me
like not knowing who you're voting for
well i trust the people who researched
it you can't i mean like it's it's no
different than any other consumer
decision like i don't know everything
about the [ __ ] you know i trust reviews
i trust things that i trust like people
trust you right you say something on
your show they trust you they know that
you're authentic and real and honest and
they trust what you say so and you know
so someone if your friend says hey this
guy's a really good guy you vote for him
you trust me
that's usually because i'm like you guys
got to make sure you fact check this one
and do your own research you shouldn't
just blindly follow and and they'd say
the same thing and if they get it wrong
there are people who will criticize them
in forums and stuff like that it's not a
process without feedback but like i
don't want to pay attention to politics
right that's not i'm that's not my thing
i think politics is mostly dumb um i
mean i want to win so i have to engage
in it right
but i don't really like politics and so
if someone else is will that i trust is
willing to do that research and identify
the candidates that share my values you
know why not outsource it why not
freeride peer review is very powerful
for um for like
anonymous social media if you want to be
anonymous online but you have enough
peers that can verify that based on what
your account's doing that that is ian
crossland then you can kind of trust
that it's me without knowing who i am
yeah yeah that's what identity is
identity is all statements that other
people make right like my id is the new
hampshire government saying that i'm
jeremy kaufman thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you